the number of people being taken to
hospital with coronavirus symptoms
is growing every day our critical care
units
are already full and we are asking our
healthcare
and social care staff who have already
done
so much to work even harder
unless we act the nhs will not be able
to look after the increasing number of
people who are falling
seriously ill even with the extra
five thousand beds that we have
available
for this winter and most likely of all
even more people will die from this
deadly virus
and if that is the position then we
would have to take even more extreme
measures
to bring the virus back under control we
will be looking at an open-ended
national lockdown such as the one we had
in march
of this year now over
the weekend the cabinet of the welsh
government met
to continue our discussions about a time
limited fire break a short sharp shock
to turn back the clock slow down the
virus
and give us more time we met again
this morning and we have now reached
the difficult decision to introduce
a two-week fire break starting
at 6 p.m on friday this week
the fire break period will then
include the half term holiday
and cover the weeks ending on monday
the 9th of november this fire break is
the shortest
we can make it but that means that it
will have to be
sharp and deep in order to have
the impact we need it to have on the
virus
between friday the 23rd of october
and the 9th of november everyone in
wales
will be required to stay at
home this means working from home
wherever that is possible and the only
exceptions
will be critical workers and jobs where
working from home
is simply not possible
all non-essential retail leisure
hospitality and
tourism businesses will close just as
they had to
during the march lockdown community
centres libraries and recycling centers
will close
places of worship will be closed for
normal services
other than for funerals or wedding
ceremonies